السيده الاولى الاوكرانيه
تصلوا الى باريس بحثا عن مساعدات غربيه
لتدفئه اوكرانيا خلال فصل الشتاء القارس
بدلا من 800 مليون يورو قال الرئيس
الاوكراني ان بلاده بحاجه اليها كحد ادنى
جمع المؤتمر الدولي الذي تستضيفه باريس ما
يزيد قليلا عن مليار يورو لدعم كياف بواجي
موسكو
[موسيقى]
415 مليون لقطاع الطاقه
25 مليون للمياه وثمانيه وثلاثون مليون
للغذاء وسبعه عشر مليون للصحه
22 مليون للنقل
المتبقي بحث
شارك في هذا الاجتماع 70 وفدا من دول
ومنظمات دوليه الهدف بحسب الرئيسي الفرنسي
هو تحيد استراتيجيه روسيا القائمه على قصف
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا
تهدف الى تدمير البنيه التحتيه المدنيه من
اجل ترفيع اوكرانيا لذلك الضروره الفوريه
تمت دعوته 500 شركه فرنسيه من الشركات
العملاقه والناشئه لاجراء محادثه ثنائيه
مع المسؤولين الاوكرانيين في ما يخص مش
اريع اعاده الاعمار في اوكرانيا